JOSH TETRICK: Thanks, Jessica,
for hanging out and eating
all that egg-less mayo.
It's good to be here with
you, and hi to everyone
watching on the live stream.
I'm especially proud to
be here with this man
because I have been doing
this for only five years,
and decades ago, when I
was playing football trying
to figure my life out, Wayne
was fighting for animals,
figuring out a
different approach
to do all the good that
we'll be talking about.
And we're at Google, this is the
land of the information economy
here.
And we know about as
the information economy.
And we know that the
wealth that it's created.
We know the freedom
that it's created.
But you talk about
a different kind
of economy, the humane economy.
So I think we should
start-- what is that?
And then we'll get into a
good conversation together.
WAYNE PACELLE: Yeah.
No, that's great hey
everybody here and online.
And it's a great
pleasure to be with Josh,
who is really one of the
pioneers of the humane economy.
And you know, I think of
the history of our country
and you think of all of the
changes that have been wrought
in so many different
domains-- social issues,
I mean we're a country
that has dealt with so many
pressing social justice issues.
I mean, for the first
80 years in our history
we had chattel slavery,
for the first 140 years
we denied women
the right to vote,
as recently as the 1950s we
had violence breaking out
in the South and other parts
of the country on race issues,
we've had an incredible
kind of interest
and also enormous
movement on LGBT
issues in the last few years.
And one of the
issues that I think
is one of the most emerging
issues which, of course, is
the subject of the book, and the
reason why I chose the title,
is "The Humane Economy"
and animal issues.
But these changes are seen
not just in social issues,
but in technology.
I mean the world changes
so fast, faster than ever.
If you think about all the
different domains in which we
look at how we
conduct our lives,
how we get around, how
we process information--
it's crazy to think
of the changes.
It was wild as a notion to think
humans would engage in flight.
The transition from
the horse and the horse
and buggy to the internal
combustion engine
was obviously a huge change.
All the changes in
information technology,
in photography-- I mean, we
could go through every one.
And obviously the whole idea
of search and information
gathering is a big part of
the changes that are just
running through society.
So in this book I'm
talking about the changes
that are happening in our human
relationship with animals.
Some are very intentional,
where we are designing new ways
to live our lives
and conduct business
that reflects a greater
consciousness about animals.
And you, I think,
are a great example
of that because you
have a sensibility
and a concern for animals.
But there are other
changes that are
being wrought just
because people are
seeking greater efficiencies.
The famous statement within
the animal protection movement
and its history is
that Henry Ford, not
Henry Burke, who was the
founder of the ASPCA,
really was the one who liberated
the horse in so many ways
in the 19th century.
And I think through
intentional innovation
and just innovation-- I mean
morally intentional innovation,
versus just innovation that
comes through efficiency,
we're seeing incredible changes.
So this book is
kind of a chronicle.
It's also a little bit
of a political science
treatment of how these changes
are occurring in our society.
JOSH TETRICK: It's interesting
in thinking about "The Humane
Economy" and following
Wayne's work,
we're in a day where-- earlier
today Wayne I was discussing
earlier John Boehner in
referring to Ted Cruz--
called him, "Lucifer
in the flesh."
We got Democrats fighting with
each other, Republicans fight
with each other, and a lot
of partisanship out there.
And that the energy I get from
this book in your work, Wayne,
it feels different in tone.
And I wonder if
you could describe
that a little bit, because
we-- everyone, whether you love
your dog, you love your cat,
or you just think that animals
generally should
be treated better,
can come to a common
agreement that,
best not to do a lot of harm.
But there's a tone
to it, and I wonder
if you could touch
a little bit on that
in the context of this
book in your work.
WAYNE PACELLE: Well you
referenced my involvement
in this issue for many years
and I've been at it a long time.
I was a sophomore in
college in the mid-80s
and I started in
animal advocacy group.
At the time I think it was
really almost a protest
movement.
I mean these ideas were
not top of mind for people.
The whole term animal rights
was kind of an unusual one,
it was a very provocative one.
And to even talk about
things like agriculture
and think about eating
more plant-based foods,
talk about being a
vegetarian, those
were a bit heretical
at that time.
And I think over
these last 30 years,
we've seen these ideas move from
the margins to the mainstream,
and that the notion
of protecting animals
has become normalized.
And the idea that cruelty
to animals is wrong
is a universal value.
Every single state has
an anti-cruelty statute
that forbids malicious
treatment of individual animals.
And now, thanks to South
Dakota passing a law in 2014,
all 50 states have
felony level penalties
for these malicious
acts of cruelty.
So I think, and to
your point, Josh,
the basic issue that animal
cruelty is wrong is settled.
The difficulty comes in
applying anti-cruelty principles
in a world where
animals are embedded
in so many different
industries in our society.
They're embedded in
food and agriculture.
A lot of people
don't think about it.
We get our food
from a cafeteria.
And obviously you guys
actually do fabulous food here,
Bon Appetite management
does your food service here
and they're an absolutely
leader in humane and sustainable
eating issues.
So it's great to have
the marriage of these two
fabulous companies.
But these notions of treating
animals well in the food system
may not be intuitive to people
because we're so far removed
from the food system.
We get our stuff in the
cafeteria, as I was saying,
or from a restaurant
or from a supermarket,
and we don't know the back
story unless we actively
search it out or if we've
had some opportunity to now
see a documentary
or to read about it.
And what you're
doing, Josh, I think
is an incredible business
venture because you
are giving people choices.
We were hostage before because
the standard American diet--
we were told when
I was growing up,
the US department
of agriculture had
a construct for the ideal diet
called the basic four food
groups.
And you were basically
told you were
going to be unhealthy--
kids, especially boys,
who want to grow
fast and they want
to have muscles and
be strong-- they
were told that you have to eat
from each of these four food
groups liberally.
So you've got meat
in one category,
and then dairy and eggs
in a second category,
then all the fruits
and vegetables
were bunched into one
even though there are so
many different fruits
and vegetables,
and then you have
grains in the other.
And this was how industry
worked through the government
to project what we
were supposed to eat.
And we've been told through
all these government programs
that meat makes you strong,
you need the protein.
If you eat plant-based foods
you're going to be deficient.
And what you've
done-- and I'm sure
most people here know
what Hampton Creek is,
and Jessica gave us
that introduction--
but you're producing
a plant-based egg,
that-- people have
no idea that eggs
are hidden in so many products.
They're in muffins, and they're
in cakes, and they're in pasta,
and they're ingredients
and so many other foods
and we don't even see it.
So you're creating an
opportunity for people
to have all the good things
that eggs do for us in terms
of protein and other
nutritional properties--
having the binding
qualities of the product
because it's an ingredient
that keeps things together--
but with none of
the animal cruelty.
And that's why I was so happy to
profile Josh and his colleague
and my colleague, Josh Balk, in
the book, because I think you
guys are incredible
innovators and I
guess I just wanted to ask
you as someone who I think
is providing choices
to people, what's
the balance between
like your innovation
and your moral purpose here?
How do you navigate that?
JOSH TETRICK: When we
started five years ago--
if I don't know if I would
have said this publicly five
years ago, but if we were
having a private conversation
together-- and you asked
me about the biggest food
companies in the world and the
biggest retailers in the world,
I would said they mostly
don't get it at all.
I would have said
that they're made up
of people who--
they're fine, but they
don't have a lot of compassion.
They don't have a lot
of goodness in them.
And one thing we've learned
in the last five years
is that's actually
wrong, and it leads
to how we think about
things and balancing that.
We have found out that when
you approach food, this thing,
this system that is
so personal, that
is so connected to our
identity, in a way that is not
about clashing with
folks, in a way that
is built on our identity,
in a way where--
just like everyone agrees that
animals shouldn't be treated
cruelly-- everyone also agrees,
all things being equal-- food--
there's a little bit
better for the body
and a little bit
better for the planet--
should taste better
and be affordable.
There's not a lot
of disagreement.
Whether you go to a Donald
Trump rally or a Bernie Sanders
support, you probably
agree with that.
And we believe that as long
as we can figure out a way
to make that good thing taste
better and be more affordable,
change is instigated by that.
So in some ways we don't feel
like we're sacrificing profits.
That is connected to how
we think about things now,
we do things.
And I know then in thinking
about the humane economy,
we establish this baseline.
Everyone-- doesn't
matter who you are,
there's some baseline care
that's been recognized legally,
it's been recognized
culturally, it's
been recognized
morally for animals.
And you got
entrepreneurship trying
to do something about it.
But one thing you've done
in your organization,
HSUS has done, is
to say that what
your General Mills or Nestle or
Walmart, or you're Burger King
or you're McDonald's, there are
good people in these companies,
that if approached in the
right way, agree with this.
WAYNE PACELLE: Because most
people want to do good.
This whole notion that
somehow that everybody's
bad-- populating these
enormous companies is false.
And we've seen that in
terms of our campaigns
in getting companies to
just procure their eggs
from cage-free operations.
So many of the companies
now are sourcing
some of your Hampton
Creek products,
which is an amazing thing.
How many stores are you in now?
JOSH TETRICK: Today we're
about 21,000 locations,
you can find us in 2,300 public
schools, 472 universities,
every single solitary Walmart.
We're in fancy restaurants like
Beefsteak in Washington, DC.
We're also in places
like the Dollar Tree
that you might not
expect us to be in.
WAYNE PACELLE: Because
you're competitive on price?
JOSH TETRICK: Because
we figure out a way
to be competitive in price.
And every once and again
you find these individuals
at these companies who figure
out a way to really align
the profit and the purpose.
And you mentioned Bon
Appetite, who runs food here,
I think they're a part of it.
I think the wider Compass group,
a big food service company,
is a part of it.
executives at Walmart, you
know, Wayne, are a part of it.
And I think that bodes well
in the intro to your book
in talking about suffering
and talking about torture
and talking about devastation
of animals you said hope
and you talked about that.
And what are-- in doing all
this research spending, all
this time while you're running
in this big organization-- what
are one or two bright spots
of just scintillating hope
that you see out there?
You're just like, you look
at it for the folks in here
who love animals, and you
say quit the pessimism.
Something's going on here.
WAYNE PACELLE: Well,
we're at a moment
of great change in our society.
We do recognize that
animal cruelty is wrong.
We now do see the
power of the human mind
to figure out ways
to do things better.
So if you've got a moral purpose
and you have a moral problem,
how do we solve that problem?
Let's figure out a way to
meet our basic needs, let's
figure out a way to
generate jobs and wealth
but not leave a trail of
animal victims in the process.
And I think one of the
big conclusions in my book
is that if you look at different
sectors of the economy,
you would get food and ag,
wildlife management, fashion,
use of animals in
cosmetic testing,
chemicals, drug testing,
other domains, we're
seeing incredible gains across
the board in all these areas.
If you saw one area
that was popping up
because you had a visionary
entrepreneur like you,
or you had a terrible
incident that
came to light and that
raised consciousness
and then people
responded to that,
you say OK, well that
was just that set
of facts and circumstances
that drove that outcome.
But when you see last
month that SeaWorld
said it's going to end
its breeding of orcas
just three years
after the release
of "Blackfish" the movie,
that was serially run on CNN,
and the year before that
Ringling Brothers said
it was going to end its use
of elephants in circus acts,
I mean those are two big brands
in the world of live animal
entertainment, in fact,
with elephants and orcas
right at the center
of the brand.
For those companies to change
is symbolically significant.
I mean, it may not affect the
lives of that many animals,
certainly not relative
to agriculture,
but it's a big deal.
When Cecil the lion
was killed last July
and this Minnesota trophy
hunter, the bow and arrow
had his face splash
all over social media
and traditional media, I mean
the world responded to that.
And within three weeks, 45 of
the biggest global airlines,
including all the
big US carriers--
Delta, American,
and United-- said,
we're not going to ship
trophies in our cargo
hold of African lions
or elephants or rhinos
or Cape Buffalo or leopards.
So the world is changing.
Cosmetic companies-- it used
to be just the regular process
for all these cosmetic
makers to test
on animals with a
lethal dose 50 test,
or the Draize eye
irritancy test.
And now you have hundreds
of these companies
that have said we
are not going to test
our products on animals.
They're using safe
ingredients and they're
using alternative methods.
And then this revolution in
food with, in the last seven
months, 140 of the biggest
brand names in food,
from McDonald's, to Walmart
to Burger King, to Sodexho,
to Norwegian Cruise
Lines-- I mean,
every name you could
think of, they've
all committed to source their
eggs from cage-free operations.
So you see that in all
these different arenas
something's happening.
Now it's a dizzyingly
complex world
in terms of our human
relationship to animals
and there are still so
many enormous problems.
But for me, it does
give me hope because it
shows that our focus in
trying to drive change
can yield results.
If we are good enough and
strong enough as organizations
to drive this, we're
going to find great people
within these
companies, we're going
to reach consumers who are
increasingly concerned.
Young people have now had
access because of Google
and other information
aggregators
to find out what's happening
to animals on factory farms
or to find out what's
happening in cosmetic testing
laboratories or to expose Walter
Palmer for shooting that lion.
This information is closing
the distance between our world
and what happens to animals.
And I think the other part of
this, which I kick back to you,
is people have to have options.
If you're living in some small
rural part of the United States
and you get a
little airport, you
may be lucky if there's
one commercial carrier who
is offering service
to you if you
need to travel long distance.
So you're a hostage
to that one company.
You got to get your flight when
then leave and at the price
you want because you
don't have a choice.
You can't drive 1,000 miles.
So that's the way
it was with eggs,
that's the way it was
with a lot of products.
We didn't have choices.
And now you with your
company are giving people
choices that enable people
then to act on their beliefs.
And if you're concerned about
the mistreatment of animals
in the food supply,
here's one way
to just kind of keep
things perfectly clean
and eat the products
that you're providing
that are equivalent or superior
on nutrition and price,
and way superior on
the moral side of it.
And I imagine that's why you
think you're seeing success
in all of this.
JOSH TETRICK: I
mean we the way we
think about it is whether
we're making a cookie or Mayo
or dressings or pasta--
whatever the heck it is we're
making as a company-- that we
got 310 million Americans, 7.1
billion people on the planet.
A tiny fraction of
those folks, let's
call them just not good at all.
Like flat out evil,
tiny fraction of them.
We want the evil folks
out there to eat our stuff
because it is more delicious
than anything else out there
and is more affordable than
anything else out there.
You got a lot of people in
this world that are poor.
They're just poor
and they simply
don't have a lot of options.
And all things
being equal they'd
feed their kids good
things, but unfortunately,
just like my mom, growing up,
she didn't have a lot of money
to do the right thing.
We want the poor
people out there
to end up choose in the
thing that is more connected
to who they are,
connected to their values
because it's more affordable
and because it tastes better.
Right?
WAYNE PACELLE: Yep.
JOSH TETRICK: And there
are a lot of people, Wayne,
as we all know, I mean
especially the people who
work at one of the most
extraordinary companies
in the world that we're talking
to now, who were just too damn
busy.
Just too busy-- you have
a thousand things going on
in your life and you can't
contemplate ethical choices
every single moment.
We all should, of course,
but it makes it difficult.
Our system has made
that difficult.
So if you can make it easy for
the busiest people in the world
to do the right thing by just
having it delicious, having it
available everywhere,
you don't have to take
20 little steps or
big steps to get it,
then you end up hopefully
doing something better.
WAYNE PACELLE: It goes from
a niche sort of concern.
I say that people who are
really concerned about animals
will sacrifice.
When I was eating in
the dining hall in 1984,
we didn't have a Bon
Appetite management
that our university
was sourcing from,
and I had to go in the back with
the cooks and make my own food.
And I was like not
a very good cook.
I was giving them
advice and showing them
how to use tofu and
these other things.
I was willing to go in
the back and to deal
with that and the
inconvenience of it,
and then walking
out in the dining
hall with this different thing
that everyone is mocking me
for it, talking about.
And now that has a
low ceiling in terms
of the number of
people do that, but we
want to reach 95%, not 5%.
JOSH TETRICK: That's it.
Think about it, to use another
analog outside the world
of food, this food system.
And I know that the
folks at this company
think in terms of systems.
And think about energy.
Think how many times in your
life you've walked into a room
and you've flipped
a light switch.
And that light switch has
set off a chain of reaction
that has gone to
a coal-fired power
plant within 65 square miles.
I guarantee you that 99%
of the folks who work here
believe in the science
of climate change.
You believe we
should do something
to mitigate
extinction, you believe
in protecting the environment.
Every time you flip
that switch you're
doing something that's
misaligned with your values.
Not because you're a bad
person, but because it's easy,
it's accessible, and it works.
WAYNE PACELLE: You're a hostage.
JOSH TETRICK: It's
bound in the system.
And I think figuring out
a way through the laws--
and I'd love you to
touch on that too, Wayne,
through laws, through
commerce, through working
with the biggest companies, is
unraveling the system to create
something a little bit better.
And on that, we talk
about entrepreneurship.
You talk about some of
these biggest companies who
have figured out a way to
say we don't need to confine,
we can have a little
bit more freedom.
We don't need to cram,
we can have a little bit
more openness.
But the Humane Society
has done really
trailblazing work
at understanding
how to unpack the legalities,
of the laws-- state,
national around all this.
Maybe you could
touch a little bit
on that, how that opens up
this human economy, too.
WAYNE PACELLE: Well I
wrote a piece not long ago
for "Foreign Affairs"
magazine about the interplay
of strategy.
So congressional strategies,
state legislative strategies,
ballot measures, as well
as corporate campaigns,
the courts.
You think of the
gay rights cause.
We were doing ballot measures
in states for the last 25 years.
And we were outlawing
cockfighting
of the use of steel jaw leg hold
traps or confinement systems
for animals on factory farms.
And on the same ballot with
us were often anti-gay rights
ballot measures.
In fact, when we did
prop 2 here seven,
eight years ago
to ban confinement
of animals on
factory farms, prop 8
was on the was on the ballot,
which was a anti-gay marriage
measure.
And that measure passed
while prop 2 also passed.
So it was an incredible
run of losses
that the gay rights
community had
on those sets of those
gay marriage questions.
Like 32 straight or
something that they lost.
But they kept at it
and their big arena
of success or pathway of
success was through the courts.
Once more people came
out of the closet
and started talking about
their sexual orientation,
it just became part of society.
And the whole fear of
it was demystified.
And the numbers in terms of
acceptance of these ideas
flipped in society where it was
fewer than 50% of the people
were tolerant of
that lifestyle, then
it became a majority sentiment.
Then the courts
invalidated those
states statutes, invalidated
federal laws that
discriminated.
And one of the things
that I've seen in our work
is that we're working all
these different channels.
Sometimes we're
working the courts,
and then we're
working the Congress,
and we're doing ballot
measures and we're
working these corporations.
We had a case where the
egg industry actually
agreed to set a minimum standard
and service of space allocation
and enrichment standards for
the hands in agriculture.
And the other sectors of
the farm lobby, the beef
and the pork industry
and the Farm Bureau
blocked it in Congress.
But it didn't stop us, because
then we just went around.
And my colleague Josh
Balk and Paul Shapiro
started talking to the big food
sellers in the United States
and said, hey, we've
got a majority of people
who care about these issues.
Look at these polls.
85% of people don't want to see
animals in extreme confinement.
Look at what California did when
this issue was on the ballot.
Look at the health
issues, look at the brand
that you're trying to build.
You don't want to be associated
with the sort of animal
cruelty.
And so many of these
companies have changed.
So what an incredible thing to
see how these reinforcements--
when we do a ballot
measure it sets up
the corporate campaigns.
When we do a
corporate campaign, it
sets up success for
a ballot measure,
it sets up success
in the courts.
And one of the things that
I'm most excited about
is that people like you
are now making it easier.
We just came from Veggie
Grill, a new company.
It's like a fast food
type plant-based company.
I couldn't have stopped
there years ago.
It didn't exist.
And so many companies
are now working
to give us more options.
And I guess had a
question for you.
Might be a tough
question, but you
see that HSUS has negotiated
all these agreements
with these big food
companies on cage-free eggs,
and here you are with a
plant-based egg substitute.
Are you concerned?
Are we undermining
you with this idea
of a more cage-free as the
minimum standard in society?
Because that's what's going to
happen to me over the next six
or seven years,
all the cages are
going to be pulled out of
these enormous factory farms.
You're still going to
have intensive raising
of laying hens.
They're going to be big
buildings in a lot of cases,
but does that concern you
from a business perspective?
JOSH TETRICK: No,
I thind-- I heard
someone say-- I
wish I remembered
who said this because it
has always impacted me.
Compassion is like a muscle.
The more you work, it
the stronger it gets.
And these executives of
the biggest companies
in the world, executives
that are, in a lot of ways,
they're influencing these
billions of dollars of food
flows.
Is it bad?
Is it good?
Is it easy to eat well?
Is it hard to eat well?
When Humane Society, in a
thoughtful, intellectual,
rational way describes the
market, describes the options,
you begin to open up the mind
and the heart to these things.
When we go in and we
have conversations,
there's an openness, there's an
awareness of what's happening.
And the reality,
Wayne, is we didn't
start Hampton Creek
to do anything
but try to use the force of
capitalism to have an impact.
We want it to happen
all over the place
and we want more companies
to read your book
to try to compete with us.
That's how change
really happens.
WAYNE PACELLE: Yeah,
you know I have
a chapter in this
book that really
is about the innovators in
the food and agriculture area.
And the preceding
chapter is really
about the cage-free and
create-free movement,
and kind of running the
table on that issue.
And we will see the end
of extreme confinement
in the United States in
just the next few years.
But what you're doing
at Hampton Creek,
and what Beyond Meet is
doing and Impossible Foods,
and also what Modern Meadow is
doing in terms of cell culture
meat, I talk about this
chapter where I feature you
and Josh Balk and others.
And the title of this chapter is
called "The chicken or the egg,
or neither?"
And I start off with this quote
from Winston Churchill, 1931,
in an essay titled
"50 Years Hence."
Now Winston Churchill
is a visionary guy,
but I never knew this
dimension of him.
He said we shall escape
the absurdity of growing
a whole chicken in
order to eat the breast
or wing by growing
these parts separately
under a suitable medium.
Synthetic food will,
from the outset,
be practically indistinguishable
from natural products.
And think about this guy nearly
a century ago saying that.
I mean, it is kind of
crazy at some level.
I mean, these animals, putting
them by the tens of thousands
in the case of laying
hens in a single building?
I went to one farm
in Iowa that had
150,000 hens jammed in the cages
that were stacked eight high.
The cages were side to side
for a football field length.
And they were 93 houses,
there were 10 million birds
at this complex.
There are three million
people in all of Iowa.
Our media chases these
people around Iowa
for months in advance of the
Iowa caucuses every four years.
There are 99 counties
in that state.
Think of it, one farm
had 10 million birds.
And you think, as my
friend Matthew Scully said,
factory farming is a case
of human ingenuity detached
from conscience.
What if we could have
agriculture and human ingenuity
attached to conscience?
That's really what
you're trying to do.
You're creating an
efficient company
that can produce affordable,
nutritious, complete food,
but without any of
the moral problems
that we typically associate
with these industrialized
agriculture notions.
I guess is why I feel
hopeful, because I
look at the history
of our country
and I see all the changes.
And if we're determined to
solve these problems-- I mean,
we can entertain people
without having elephants
standing on their head.
We can feed ourselves
without cramming
buildings full of animals
on a factory farm.
We can entertain
ourselves in the wild
without having a bow and arrow,
and we can take a camera out
and watch the wildlife.
These are not super hard
problems, it seems to me.
For our society we've got
a lot of tough problems,
but these don't seem
to be among them.
JOSH TETRICK: And when you were
sneaking back in the dining
hall trying to teach those
chefs how to make something
or cooking it yourself,
you called it--
WAYNE PACELLE: I didn't
go into that field
because I had a low ceiling
in terms of my ability.
JOSH TETRICK: Yeah,
join the club.
But you called it,
back in the day,
kind of a protest movement.
WAYNE PACELLE: Yeah
JOSH TETRICK: One of
the-- getting back
to things I'd been surprised
about in the last five years
is billionaires
across the world,
influential legislatures--
locally, globally,
nationally-- executives
at the biggest companies
in the world, celebrities.
It feels like the last 5 to 10
years, these influential people
who determine what we
watch, what we buy,
where capital goes into
have almost collectively,
at the same time, said
what are we doing?
Maybe there's a better path.
And I want to talk a little
bit about that because you
can have a deep
grassroots movement,
but the reality of the
world that we live in,
whether we want to
accept it or not,
is influential folks
hold a lot of power
in politics and finance.
What do you see in there?
What's going on?
WAYNE PACELLE: Well leadership
matters in the world.
I don't see social
change as just these kind
of winds that are blowing
that carry us along.
People do influence history.
And 25 years ago, when
David Duffield, who started
PeopleSoft became the
first big philanthropist
in the world of animal welfare.
He said I'm going
to put $2 billion
into eliminating euthanasia of
dogs and cats in this country.
The Wall Street Journal and
other publications mocked him.
Why would you do that?
Now we're seeing major
philanthropists and investors
really saying, hey, we need
to make our society better.
So you've got billionaires
investing in your company
because they see that it's
good for the whole society.
When your company
grows, your values
are embedded in the products
that you're selling,
and that's going to turn
out to be a better society.
And we're seeing philanthropists
putting more money
into these causes, and that
is transformational for us.
Because you need that
kind of leadership.
You need people to step up
and imagine a better world.
If we just wait for these
things to happen, it won't.
It always has taken human
agency to drive big change.
And what's more fundamental than
changing our human relationship
to nature and animals?
Animals are all around us,
nature is all around us.
One of the most iconic images
in contemporary American history
was when in the late 1960s
when astronauts went into space
with our government funding,
so much of that research
and development and
then that space travel,
astronaut looked back and took
a picture in the vast openness
of our solar system and saw this
little blue-green marble amidst
all the darkness of
our solar system, which
is a small portion
of our galaxy, which
is one galaxy among
countless galaxies.
And we saw how
fragile this earth is.
70% of it is covered by water
of the terrestrial landscape.
So much of that is covered
by desert and rock and ice.
The habitable
portion is limited.
It is madness that we have
77 billion animals being
raised for food on
this planet every year.
77 billion.
It's one person to 11 animals.
The average person in this
world is eating 11 animals.
In the United States, we're
eating 30 animals a year,
per person.
We cannot afford this.
When I was in conversation the
other night with Mark Bittman,
he said if the rest of the
world adopts the American diet
in terms of our animal
product consumption,
we're going to need four earths.
We cannot afford this.
It's terrible from an
animal welfare outcome,
it's horrible from an
environmental perspective
in terms of groundwater, the
atmosphere, use of grains,
use of water.
I mean, these are fundamentals.
And that's why we need people
like you and others figuring
out a new way to feed
ourselves in a way that's
good and affordable,
but that doesn't
create this enormous
set of casualties.
JOSH TETRICK: I want to
make sure-- we're really
lucky to be here, in particular,
a company I admire a lot.
And I'd love to take a
few questions from you
all, and we'll continue
the conversation
whether questions specifically
about Wayne's book,
his career, this crazy world of
food that we find ourselves in
and the optimism that I think is
around this more than we often
realize.
You can just step up to--
the mic's over there.
AUDIENCE: Hey guys.
Thank you for the
wonderful presentation.
Always inspiring to
hear both of you.
And my question for you, Wayne,
is you touched on legislation,
and can you talk
about the type of work
that the Humane Society
of the United States
is doing on legislation,
both on softening bills that
could be harmful for
animals, and also
propelling bills forward
that could be helpful.
WAYNE PACELLE:
Sure, we want to use
all these different
channels to drive reform.
And there's such an
asymmetry in power
between humans and animals.
We hold all the cards, we
can wipe out entire species,
we can have factory
farms, we can
stage fights between animals.
So the law has to speak for
animals because the animals are
so vulnerable.
And we're working to pass basic
anti-cruelty laws, and then
laws and all these different
arenas in which we're working,
whether that's cracking
down on puppy mills
or banning trophy hunting
of wolves or grizzly bears,
or it's ending cosmetic
testing on animals
or ending confinement or
tail docking of dairy cows.
But we also do find ourselves
trying to block bad bills,
and the agriculture
industry has really
been responsible for
some doozies out there.
One category of laws
or bills that they've
been trying to pass are
what we have referred--
and Mark Bittman, a food
writer for The New York Times
said, our ag gag laws, to
forbid citizens or staff
from groups like the Humane
Society of the US or the Humane
League or Mercy for Animals
from taking pictures or video
of animals on factory farms.
Now this is the food that
people in society are eating.
Kids are eating,
grandparents are eating.
And we're not allowed to see it
if it's an unauthorized image
from these farms?
So you see whenever you
have any social progress,
there's a backlash from the
people who are very invested
in maintaining the status quo.
So now they have
right to farm laws.
There were bills introduced
in Oklahoma and Missouri
this year to prevent
Oklahomans and Missourians
from contributing to animal
protection organizations that
do national programs.
It was a transparent
attempt to try
to dry up our fund raising
at the Humane Society
because the Farm
Bureau and the others
don't want us doing this work.
AUDIENCE: Hey Wayne, can you
tell us a little bit more
about your career
path to becoming
the CEO for the Humane Society?
Prior to this talk I hadn't
realized that was a role.
And then for both of you,
I want to learn more about
what are the biggest challenges
that your organizations are
facing, and particularly
what can Googlers do to help.
WAYNE PACELLE: I had a
lifelong love of animals.
It wasn't just that I liked
having dogs or other animals
around me, I had a real
empathy for all animals.
I mean, I didn't
want animals to be
harmed if they were
whales in the ocean
or wolves in a national park.
And I wrote a book five
years ago called "The Bond",
where I argue that we humans
have an instinctive connection
to other creatures.
That's built into us.
If you look at our human
history, 99% of our history
was that tribal societies
and hunters and gatherers
and we were immersed in nature.
And today we live in these
urban and suburban environments
where we're disconnected,
at some level,
from some aspects of nature.
But we bring it into our world
in the form of pet keeping,
and we also go and
enjoy it in terms
of visiting parks and
other places where
we can experience nature.
So animals were always
part of my outlook
and I always wanted
to do right by them.
When I was a kid growing up I
had no idea about the many ways
that we exploit
animals, especially
on a large scale,
institutionalized scales.
And I decided when I was a
college student that I didn't
want to be a bystander anymore.
I saw what was happening with
factory farming and trophy
hunting and these
other problems,
and I said I got to
do something about it.
So I started as a grassroots
advocate and I just
volunteered, and one
thing led to another,
and I started
writing in the field.
And then I've been
just kind of moving up,
and it's been a real
privilege to serve at HSUS.
I've been CEO for 11 years,
and it's a life passion for me.
And there was no-- I'm
not a nonprofit management
executive that's moving
in different sectors.
I'm wanting to stop animal
cruelty in the world,
basically.
JOSH TETRICK: Joanna, you
asked a question about how
Google could help, right?
I'll throw out something,
and there's always
an opportunity here when you're
in front of intelligent people
to hopefully do a
little bit more good.
I can think of a couple ways.
One is we're lucky to have
Jessica as an advisor investor
to the company.
And Jessica here at Google
has her own particular set
of skills and communications
and strategic communications
and marketing and
branding and leadership.
And she helps us.
What are yours?
You particular skills,
whether it's in data science,
whether it's in
hardcore analytics,
whether it's in graphic
design, whether it's in food.
You and your skills can help
entrepreneurs understand
where they're going,
whether as a volunteer,
whether as an advisor.
You and your skills can
help nonprofit organizations
that we can talk more about even
outside of the Humane Society
open up the humane
economy even more.
Your money can be used if you
believe in the human economy.
You believe in
these common values
that we share can be used
to instigate legislation
that is supportive of animals.
So those are a few
ways I think now
that when you think
about very concrete ways,
if you believe this,
and it's hard not to,
you can bring your
energy to bear
and hopefully do a
little bit more good.
WAYNE PACELLE: Yeah, don't
leave it up to us, right?
We all have a role
to play in society.
And you said it
beautifully, Josh.
Tap into your special talents,
tap into your passions.
We want to find a place for
you at HSUS to work with us,
whether it's one hour a
month or 10 hours a week--
whatever it is.
But I think you also
hit on it, that we
are voting for and
against animal cruelty,
for and against sustainability
with our dollars
in the marketplace
every single day.
We've got to be
conscious consumers.
The reason that so many
companies and cosmetics
and food are changing
is because they're now
registering that sentiment
that exists in the marketplace,
saying, hey, we've got
to change because people
are figuring this out.
So the more we can add people
to that mass consumer movement,
the stronger we're going
to be, the easier our job
is going to be.
JOSH TETRICK: We got we
got two minutes left.
I'm going to give you
a curve ball here.
Not to ask you a question
about the humane economy,
necessarily, but I think
the depth of where it comes.
From you mentioned
a book that you've
written about five
years ago, "The Bond."
And if you haven't read it,
you should check it out.
It talks about,
in many ways also,
the science of our
connections with animals, too.
There is a passage
about mirror neurons.
I remember the book, this young
boy was playing with his puppy.
And you were talking about
how the synapses were
dancing with each other.
And this idea that there's
this common bond that we
have to animals, not just a
dog, not just a cat, but even
chickens that we
can't see, I think
it feels to me like this
undergirdness, this foundation,
upon which the humane
economy was born.
WAYNE PACELLE: Yeah.
JOSH TETRICK: Maybe
you can just end it
with a little bit--
what is that about,
and how central is that
fundamental principle?
WAYNE PACELLE: I think that our
concern and interest in animals
is not just a social construct,
it's something that's part
of us, that we;re drawn to
animals like a moth is drawn
to a flame.
And I think the
importance of this, Josh,
is that we don't need to invent
a social concern for animals.
This instinctive impulse that
we have gives us a head start.
It's not the final word, though.
I mean we've got to figure out
this crazy society that we live
in, and all of these
problems that intersect
with our daily lives and kind
of disentangle it, and then
individually do
what we can and then
support groups
and companies that
are trying to solve these
problems on a macro level.
So I think that an informed
group of people in society who
are really alert to
the problems of animals
are the ones who are
going to drive the change.
It's always been a
more limited number
of people who have this idea
of a better civil society
that have carried the
rest of the people long.
And eventually people
say, oh my god,
of course that makes sense.
And you look back
and you wonder how
people didn't get it to start.
So just weaving from that
to the human economy,
the central notion
is that we've got
to marry our business and
our commerce with our values.
When you disassociate them
you get really bad outcomes.
Business is the
bulwark of our society.
It creates jobs and
wealth and gives us
opportunities for recreation
and pleasure and joy.
But in the conduct
of that work it
should reflect the things that
we care about in our society.
It's not this separate sphere
where we generate profits.
It's the place we generate
profits and create
opportunities for people
and live by the principles
that all of us care about.
So thank you very much
for participating.
JOSH TETRICK: You bet, Wayne.
WAYNE PACELLE: Thanks for
your incredible leadership.
JOSH TETRICK: I'm
honored to be here.
And I'll end it with the
humane economy isn't just
living in Wayne's book.
It's actually in the
food that you eat.
In some of the folks
in the audience.
Thanks to Jessica for lending
her talents to Hampton Creek.
It's in the leaders like Joshua
[? Bock ?] who has really
spearheaded a lot of
corporate welfare change
with Humane Society
of the United States.
It's with folks who work
at my company who've
helped put this together.
It with Bon Appetite,
the food service company
that helps to provide your food.
It is becoming systemic, and
I think that is exciting.
And that gives me hope
and it's in you, man.
And always proud to be
standing next to you
and always excited to see what
you're going to do next, Wayne.
And thank you to
everyone on Livestream.
WAYNE PACELLE: Yeah,
thank you everybody.
JOSH TETRICK: Thank
you for hanging out.
And get yourself a signed copy
of his book before you leave,
too.
Thanks, my friend.
WAYNE PACELLE: Thank you.
JOSH TETRICK: Thanks, everybody.
[APPLAUSE]